AND OPEN AS A.
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WE HAVE.
ONE BILL ON THE AGENDA S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
BIDEN.
BUT YOU HAVE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
LET ME START BY SAYING WE'RE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LAST YEAR CONSTITUENTS CAME TO
MY DISTRICT OFFICE ASKING TO
INTRODUCE A BILL TO STREAMLINE A
TRUCKING LICENSE FOR VETERANS.
AFTER RESEARCHING ISSUE MY STAFF
EVENTUALLY DISCOVERED THIS WAS
ALREADY LAW. BUT MANY VETERANS
WERE UNAWARE OF IT.
WE LEARNED.
THAT SINCE MANY VETERAN SEPARATE.
FROM THE SERVICE IN OTHERS.
FROM OTHER STATES THERE ARE
AWARE OF THE BENEFITS ALREADY
GIVEN TO THEM BY CALIFORNIA WHEN
THEY MOVE HOME.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN CLOSES
INFORMATION GAP IN ONE FORM
VETERANS OF ALL THE LICENSING
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA OFFERS TO
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED.
OKAY. WELL THAT WAS THAT PERVERT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
WHO TEST MONEY IN SUPPORT?
CAPTION IN CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL.
PHONE SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS YES
LORRAINE PLASS STATE LEGISLATIVE
CHAIR FOR AMERICAN VETERANS AND
THAT SUPPORTS.
PER LORD AGREES FOR MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF CHAPTER SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
I'M DEAN GOTHAM I'M FIRST VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL OF VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
CAN DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT.
FINALLY GO AHEAD AND HAVE THE
CLERK READ THE.
ROLL.
IRWIN HERE VOEPEL.
CHAVEZ HERE DALY. FRAZIER HERE.
GLORIA. MATHIS. MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
SALAS.
LET'S QUORUM.
RIGHT TO HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER SECOND
FIVE FRONT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS AND THE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
FIGHTING OF THE CLERK PLEASE.
CALL.
PROMOTE IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE
VOEPEL.
CHáVEZ. CHAVEZ I.
DALY. DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI. QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
SEVEN ZERO STILL THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH.
LOVE FIERY.
OKAY THE SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAVA
CHAVEZ AND THAT IS S. B. FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AND SJR TWENTY SIX.
PLEASE TO THE ROLL CALL.
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
BUT HAVE AYE. CHáVEZ. CHáVEZ I
A DAILY. DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS AND WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR.
.
FIVE MINUTES.
SEPHORA SIX FOUR ELEVEN WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE.
SELECT.
PLEASE SB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
SO.
PATTERSON SAID MICHAEL NJIT WAS
FROM A COUPLE OF EGGS
AND I DON'T HAVE A. HOUSING.
WE ARE WE ARE WAITING.
POSSIBLY.
TO.
IT THE MOON APPEAR ó THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE TRY TO TAKE A.
MAKE YOUR TIME IS VERY FEDERAL
WORK WITH
OUR RIGHTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARY
SUE CHIEF WE'VE ALL. GO AHEAD
AND HAVE THE CLERK GO THROUGH
THE. BILL'S.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
MURATSUCHI HIGH WHERE CITY I IN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MURATSUCHI
HI MURATSUCHI AYE. ALRIGHT. AYE
SIR.
YOU. LOST. YOUR WAY FOR ALL
RELAXED. RIGHT HE HAS LIKE YES
NINETY SECONDS
AND I. DON'T
OUR RIGHTS AND OUR VERY LAST
MEMBER. OF COURSE IT'S TEN
MINUTES.
IT THAT IT'S TEN AFTER SO I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW
EFFICIENTLY THAT'S COMMITTEE WAS
RUN. I KNOW HOW JACQUI OWNS A
COMMITTEE.
RIGHT.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN GLORIA
AYE GLORIA HIGH.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR GLORIA
AYE AYE GLORIA AYE.
VERY GOOD.
AND WITH THAT WE ADJOURN THE
MEETING